hello everyone and welcome to a really
incredible game from round 10 of the
2019 isle of man chess tournament it's a
world champion Magnus Carlsen against
Russian Grand Master maximal akov and
this game is really full of tile moves
disgusting engine lines missed
opportunities it really has they're all
really just a wild roller coaster so I I
do hope you enjoy it because well I
believe it's gonna be a long video but
for very good reasons so hope you have
the time let's dive straight into it
with the white pieces cross and opens
with d4 now with Knight to f6 c4 with
east six by Black Knight to f3 and of
course we go into the Queens gambit
declined with d5 Knight to c3 in the now
c6 the semi slot with Bishop to g5 and
now h6 we have the ante Moscow variation
Bishop to h4 and now D captures on c4 as
a black decided to leave the center
white gets to expand further in the
center with E 4 and now g5 pushing the
bishop back push up to g3 and now b5
this is one of the one of the regions
where it's actually okay to to defend
your gambit pawn with h4 by Carson and
now g4 pushing the knight back or
forward in this case the Knights the a5
attacking the c6 pawn if the knight
moves and now Knight B to d7 a very
interesting line by a mother home where
he offers the c6 pawn this this idea has
been played once in 2018 between Alexis
Arana and Boris Gelfand where cerana won
a nice game and he in fact captured the
knight to c6 which can be played but it
leads to it leads to a lot of
complications that could also favor
black for example Queen to b6 now d5 and
now Bishop the b7 so here you would just
give up your light square Bishop for
this night and end to win a pawn a4
you're gonna go a six and now well white
will start to develop and then comes the
Bishop captures D captures Queen
captures captures captures you will also
trade rooks captures captures something
like that
and then you will have two you will
first have two ways to move to castle
you will not be able to capture the
knight on d5 because of just check and
after you go back to Knight captures on
e4
and so on and so on but just an idea
what happens if you capture and ceases
but it was played in this game and what
is good fun was not unable to hold it
but cross one goes for Bishop to e2 and
now comes Bishop and also Bishop d2 is a
new move in the position and it is as a
move 11 that we have a completely new
game so worship the b7 by Matlock of
Enda now Knight captures on d7 with
Queen character son d7 and now Bishop to
e5 taking advantage of this pin here
with Queen to e7 guarding the night and
now b3 this is how usually you want to
attack the flank when when black maybe
defense the the gambit that point would
be 5 then if you know the black ignores
you can also go for a 4 and so on but
here we have looked the g8 unpinning and
now comes Queen to c2 and here already
the situation on the clock is very well
it's very different across and has a
myth an hour and 38 minutes on the clock
whereas Matlock has only 45 minutes so
before attacking the knight it's uh you
know you don't really want to miss out
on an opportunity like this Knight to a4
and now c3 already on most 16 Malekith
has created a task bone on c3 with a
three by Carson trying to undermine this
pawn chain now if you capture here then
you will be also able to eliminate the
c3 pawn and now Knight to d7 now the
idea is if you go for a character son
before first black will capture the
bishop and after D captures just queen
capture son before where you don't
really gain anything by playing Queen
captures in C 3 because Queen captures
on e4 and our Jeep DuPont is hanging the
bishop is under attack C will not be
able to castle and not a pleasant
position so here cross and played Bishop
to g3 and here already this situation on
the clock is an hour and 23 minutes for
Carlsen and only 30 minutes for muffler
Cove
we have Bishop to g7 now attacking the
d4 pawn and here across and goes for
rook to d1 just defending the pawn also
possible was knife to c5 a very
interesting line after Knight captures D
captures and Queen captures we will play
a capture some before and after
characters now look to a four so you do
get a lot of development as a while but
after Queen c5 black shouldn't have any
problems here so Carson just decides to
keep everything as it is
rook to d1 just defends the pawn and now
a5 preparing to after pawn captures also
you will be able to recapture with the a
pawn
we have castles by Carlson and now you
could go for h5 to tag our do g4 pawn
but Massa call decides for Bishop to f6
he says ok let's trade the g4 point for
your h4 point and here the situation on
the clock not much has changed for cross
on an hour in 20 minutes but Matlock was
17 minutes on the clock and it's only
moved 20 here we have night the c5
Michaelson assess a had some ideas of
Bishop to c7 followed by Bishop to b6
followed by Bishop to c5 getting hold of
this diagonal and then if Knight
captures Bishop then you get a beautiful
outpost for the night on c5 but you know
that's that's just they say but ok
Knights the c5 by crossing with Knight
characters on c5 d captures and c5 and
now you don't want to allow Bishop to d6
for Carlsen so e 5 you first have to
prevent that and only on the next move
will you capture on h4 as there is
nothing cause and can do about this
we've looked at these six by Crossin and
now Bishop captures on h4 and here
Metallica is down to 12 minutes on the
clock
Magnus goes at Bishop to c4 the idea
being that okay if you if you trade now
you don't really want to do it f
captures will open up the F file for the
rook so here my talk of plays a bishop
back to g5 first and here Mozgov misses
an important tempo because a roof to g6
is what the massacre wants to play but
he he first played Bishop to g5 he
probably doesn't like that the Queen
constantly has to keep an eye on the
bishop here but here in fact rook to g6
was a very nice move for example Queen
d3 not allowing well a la other rope to
the it is possible but you don't really
gain anything by capturing right away as
you would get a very strong passed pawn
so here rook to d8 right away a capture
Sun be for a capture Sun be for and only
now birth of characters on h4 but this
is probably what Matlock Oh miss Rooke G
captures on d6 and now we
after Sundy 6 and now Queen captures on
h4 so this is one variation that would
be very nice for black for example Queen
captures any five Czech Queen back the
east 7 offering a trade and well you
just you're just okay with black here
once you get this light square Bishop
into the game everything will be will be
okay so after Bishop to c4 we have
Bishop to g5 stomatal called first
prepared Bishop to g6 but now crossing
place Queen to d3 winning a very
important tempo we have grouped to g6
and now cross and goes for f4 and here
things get really crazy because here
mother calculate e captures on f4 he has
to go for G captures on f3 a queen
captures now with a triple attack
against the f7 pawn and then just look
to g7 and this is fine for black next
move you're gonna bring the rook over to
d8 and the game continues but we have e
captures on f4 for Magnus and the now
comes the Bishop captures on f4 here I
will show a disgusting engine line as
this game is full of them he 5 is just
incredibly strong here you don't have
the option of capturing the bishop
because the f7 pawn would still be under
attack so after E 5 you would go
something like rook the g7 to add a
defender now capturing is a threat but
only now Bishop captures an f4 Bishop
captures rook captures and here the real
threat is actually e 6 you don't get to
capture the pawn because rookie 4 wins
the Queen so here let's say Queen g5
you're gonna go G 3 and here black
amazingly but black doesn't have a move
the Queen's not getting into the game
the rook is here produced as this bishop
is a pawn you're not you're not gonna be
able to get this rook into the game so
it's just a really just a powerful
position for white but ok enough of the
dirty engine lines with Bishop Jefferson
f4 by cross and Bishop captures and the
rook captures on f4 and here
matlock have went down to three minutes
on the clock he he could go for rook to
g7 but he does have problems if rule g7
guarding the f7 pond and rook f5 and now
again you have problems 'if i was coming
a 6 is coming and so on so here a matter
for played c - he wants to deflect the
White Queen
from control of the D file Coulson
captured at Queen captures in situ and
now rook captures on d6 we have C
captures on d6 and now Queen captures on
d6 and here cross and could capture on
f7 with the bishop he could capture with
the rook but as it always is in jest
most of the times the threat is stronger
than the execution so first 'if I've
saying okay I'm gonna improve my
position also now this opens up the
diagonal for the Queen if Queen captures
again but rook to e4 will win window
Queen
so here Matlock of moves with tempo with
butter Queen to c5 check King to h1 and
now Queen to III and now here's a very
very interesting position for you to
just check you're playing white here
feel free to pause the video and try to
find it the best idea of course while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations it's really not an easy
line and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show if you found bunch of
characters on f7 that's not a good move
problem is the king escapes King the
eight and now how do you continue if
Queen D one check to go for d6 it's not
a problem
the king will just go King to c7 and now
after Queen to d6 with check you're just
you're just gonna be able to hide King
to be six and now there's no good way to
continue I guess you will be able to
push your pawn for for a while but first
your rook is under attack
and the the queening square is a long
way to go so this would not would not
work and also you have some problems
guarding against checks along the back
rank if you found the rook characters on
f7 instead also doesn't work because
here black just castles Queen side and
if Queen to f5 check King to b8 e six
goes and then just c5 and although you
are very close now the the bishop gets
is a beautiful diagonal and now again
you have some problems with with this
checking sequence so here cousin played
Queen two five which I'm sure all of
your sauce congratulations on that now
the thread is Queen character son f7 of
course which is much stronger so what do
you do here King to d8 was played by
Matlock of although Quinta a
one is also a very interesting line rook
to f1 Queen to h4 check King to g1 and
now after Queen to e7 the move you have
to find is C six it's extremely strong
and here you just you can't allow for
the position to open up so you would
have to cast the Queen side to give up
the give up the pawn on f7 with a
discover check from the Queen King to b8
and now you would just win win the game
this way so of course if everything is
traded captures captures captures
captures white is just upper rook so
metallic of doesn't like the idea of
Quinta a1 and with one minute on the
clock it is very unlikely that he had
the time to calculate all of the ideas
that involve twenty-one so he played
came to d8 and here Carson just goes
Queen captures on f7 and now this well
this past pawn seems like like a very
fast pawn we have King you you don't
have the opportunity to go c5 here to
open up this diagonal because the bishop
is now hanging and b7 so keen to c8
defending the bishop and now comes a
capture son before here across and
definitely took his time there are a lot
of ways you can continue this game you
could go Queen eh-heh Queen FA to check
all of it is good but Magnus just says
your position is terrible I'm just gonna
play a captures on b4 and if you think
you have the time to capture on before
be my guest
now so much local play the Queen
captures on e5 instead giving up this
past pawn which is very interesting
because here you have a lot of tempting
moves and I'm not gonna ask you to pause
the video here because it's just crazy
but one one a funny idea is a real
character son g4 it threatens rook the
g8 mate but then comes King to b8 and
you don't really have made anymore if
Queen f8 check you're gonna block with
the Bishop Bishop c8 and now if looked
the g8 attacking the bishop now kink the
b7 and everything is defended you just
gave up your passport for nothing but
there is a line which I will show no one
can find this this is a you know
impossible to find it's b5 it's just a
stupid move I mean no one would ever
think of this move because well you
can't allow b6 if you allow b6 then your
just getting checkmated so capture some
b5 only now rook captures on g4 now
again threatening mate but now it's
different King to b8 now comes Luke the
g8 check and after Bishop to see it now
you don't really have the seventh ranked
open for your King as the Queen covers
that so here you just go Bishop to e6
just threatened to win the game on the
spot and after Queen 31 check King to h2
Queen to e5 checker
you're gonna go g3 Quinta e to check and
now you're gonna go King to h3 and here
there are no more checks this is covered
by the Queen this is covered also by the
Queen and there just aren't any more
checks so it's just game over here but
you know who would who would play b5
here is such such a crazy move and also
I'm sure cousin didn't want to allow
Matlock of to play on his time so he he
first played Queen to f8 check with King
to c7 and now comes Luke the f7 with
check King Tubby six and now a captures
and b5 with check with Queen captures on
a5 and now Queen II sorry Queen to e7
just threatening Queen captures the
bishop here with Queen to h5 with check
King to g1 and now this is why cousins
had to spend 20 minutes on calculating
all of this rook to a1 width check so
here would rook to e1 check Matlock will
finally reach time control he was
granted additional time and Magnus left
the board at this moment he didn't play
a move he just also gained you know
reach time control so he wanted to go
for a walk and when he get back got back
he played Bishop to f1 which of course
makes sense if you go King to have to
then g3 is very strong with check King
captures and Queen to g5 check allows a
queen trade and then it's very unlikely
that you will have anything here you're
on the attack you don't want to trade
Queens so here Bishop to f1 and now it's
just a it's just a hard position I will
ask you to pause the video here and try
to find the the nicest continuation for
black so try to defend this position
while I give you a couple of seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on being you know a very
resilient
you know player who never surrenders and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
it so first we're gonna explore what
happens if Bishop the a6 if Bishop
tastes sex this isn't all the great just
twin tastes seven check now you have to
move the King King a5 and you just lose
the bishop and you're getting made it
for those of you who decided that rook
captures an f1 was in fact the way to go
you could do this it's very resilient
King captures an f1 and now brush up the
a6 check King f2 and now after Queen to
c5 check you do manage the trade Queens
for example if Queen caps team captures
or you could just move the King King to
g3 and now I have two captures captures
you would have this end game where black
is up upon but you are down the exchange
most likely I went for white but for
those of you who found Queen characters
on f7 then congratulations you are you
are really amazing here at Matlock all
parts with his Queen Queen captures on
f7 and mountain Bishop to a6 now he will
grab the bishop on f1 and of course
Carlsen will have to try very hard to
you know push his advantage to a win
Crossing was going to have to check with
King to b7 and now comes Queen to d4 a
beautiful centralizing move with the
Queen because there is no way to save
the bishop
rook captures on f1 with check King to
h2 and now we're at the g4 pawn is under
attack so h5 by Matlock off and now here
here's the idea if you can create a
fortress here and all of you know that
Carson doesn't believe in fortresses the
ideal fortress would be to somehow get
your Bishop over to d5 the d5 just not
allowing any moves here because you will
not
although the bishop is also very nice
here maybe even just the bishop leave
the bishop there to control so the
Bishop and pawn controlled the b v
square and get the rook over to d5 with
the rook on d5 you regarding the h5 pawn
and there is no no breaking through this
but caution will of course try it very
hard and so this doesn't happen he goes
Queen to c5 first now with the simple
idea of just winning upon
here and here Matlock off could have
gone for I mean there is no way to save
the age five point but there is one you
could sacrifice the g3 pawn with check
for example King captures an outro
captures on h1 Carson would have to
grind unimaginably to get through this
would be very interesting to see how he
would convert this one but mother who
went to looked the b1 instead he said
okay I'm giving you the the King's
headphones I'm winning you're be
three-point and then I'm gonna make a
you know a fortress we have Queen
captures on h5 and now comes key you
cannot capture the roof right away if
you kept right away then Queen f7 check
just picks up the rook so you don't want
to allow that so came to b6 first we
have Queen captures on g4 by Crossin and
now rook captures on b3 so now the ideal
setup for fortress will be get your
Bishop over to d5 as White has a past
Jeep on so you have to put the bishop
over to the d5 square to guard the Queen
in square and you can put the rook for
example here so the rock also guards the
queening square and this would be a this
would be a decent castle
so Carson will try his best to prevent
this we have Queen to g8 making room for
the past Jeep want to start marching
forward attacking the rook and also if
you play something like rugby one also
ideas like Queen to beat check maybe are
possible not while the bishop is still
on a sex but it's very hard to
coordinate your pieces on an open board
like this and here we have rook to be
three also going for a different type of
fortress it's it's similar its you
basically make a fortress here if you
can make the bishop and the rook guard
one of the light squares so either this
one this one or this one so here if he
can get rook to d5 in and Bishop for
example d3 well not d5 but if you can
get rook to d6 and Bishop to d3 from
there both of them can guard the g6
square and the pond will never cross the
g6 square so how will cross and try to
prevent this first g4 he he says I'm
faster than then you can ever make this
fortress we've ripped the d5 now and
here the situation is 55 minutes on the
clock
followed by two minutes on the clock for
Matlock oh he burned all the time he
gained during the
he received during time control and he
has to reach the second time control
which is moved 60 so he still has two
minutes on the clock with g5 by crossing
and now push up to d3 and here just g6
by Carlsen a lot of people thought that
this was impossible because you have a
rookie g5 check King g3 and rook to g5
now just winning the pawn but in across
and calculated properly after King to f4
you cannot win the point because of just
Queen check and you pick up the bishop
so this is one way to go about it but
after ok g5 Bishop to d3 and g6 cross
indeed play it now we have Bishop
captures and Jesus there is no other way
to do it if you allow it with the point
a bit push forward is just over so
Bishop captures and g6 matric on has to
give up the bishop very unfortunately
for him and Queen captures on g6 and now
we this move 53 we enter the the endgame
and this is now we're now across that
has to be very careful he has to finish
the game within 50 moves there's the 50
move rule unless there's a pawn push or
there's a capture on the board so here
if the if it was just if there was no
point if it was just the Queen against
the king and the rook it's the field or
principle the field or endgame it's you
know a very straightforward way to win
but with a pawn it's very different I
mean not only different but also very
difficult I remember when I was studying
in games and especially rockin games I
don't remember seeing this position like
how to go about it so I don't think
anyone knows by heart have to go about
this position or if it's even possible
so I was very interested to see how
Carson will do about how Carson will do
it because in the Philidor endgame you
will just you know outmaneuver the rook
and then at some point the rook will
have to move from the safety of the King
and then you will use a series of checks
to pick up the rook but here well the
rook is constantly guarded by the pawn
let's see what happens here is this even
possible to win so King the c7 Matloff
says okay you can prove this is this is
a winning position Queen f7 check about
crossing with King to be 8 and now King
to g3 now Carson will start to bring his
king into the game Rubi g5 check with
King to f4 and now rook back to d5 okay
how is the King gonna cross the the rule
is covering all of these squares so how
how can the King get out of out of his
square the the bottom right part of the
board
quinta f8 check by cross and King Tubby
7 and now Queen to b4 check we have came
to c7 and now King to e4 ok the King got
as far as he can with King to c8 and now
Queen to b6 this is the idea force the
King away from the pawn king to d7 and
now Queens the b7 check we have King to
d6 and now Queen to c8 hoping hoping
that black will either start pushing the
pawn or move the rook well of course
black doesn't want to do that he plays
Kim to c5 and now just Queen to b8 not
allowing the King any of the squares on
the Queen side and also not allowing the
King to go back here so the King has to
go either down the board either will go
King to c4 but then you just lost if you
go looking to c4 then you'll just have
Queen to b6 and now not lost sorry I
misspoke but black will be forced to
start pushing the pawn which is
something black doesn't want to do so
here after Queen to b8 rooked h5 now
Matlock of had to move the rook and now
here comes the way and this just blew my
mind
kinked f4 so King goes back and what's
the idea why is the King going back we
have looked to default by Matlock oh and
now King to G for this is how you do it
the Queen now covers d5 square and the
King creates a wall on the fifth rank
and now the rook has to move away from
the fifth rank rather you have to move
something else if you don't want to move
the King anywhere up or down the board
King the c4 and now Queen the b6 taking
away all the squares from the from the
King it's threatening Queen captures and
c6 rook the d4 check with King to f5
finally the King is allowed up the board
or if you don't want to allow the the
King up the board would rook to d4 check
you have to play c5 but then it's again
Quinta e6 you just go came to d4 and
King to f4 look the h5 you either you
will put the pond or the rook will move
and then just let's say Quinta efore
check King to c3 and now Queen to f3
check will pick up the rook so I will
pick up the roof so not definitely not
the way to go
so after Queen to b6 we have looked to
d4 with check King to f5 finally the
across in skiing manages to make
progress and now c5 you have to move the
pawn now and now the 50 move a rule
starts over as a pawn move has been made
we have Queen to a5 by Carlsen
rook to d5 check King e6 and now route
back to d4 Queen to a4 check back cross
and King to c3 and now Queen to a3 with
check King c4 and now Queen back to a5
and here we have look to d3 you cannot
move the King otherwise you're gonna
lose the c5 pawn so look the d3 and now
again Quinta a4 check King to c3 and now
Queen the a3 checking the King and also
attacking the pawn here Queen to c4 and
now Queen to c1 check King Tubby for you
have to keep an eye on your c5 pawn and
the now comes Queen to beat you check
came to c4 and now Queen to c2 check
King to d4 and now King to d6 now
there's no way to keep on defending your
your c5 pawn here you have to push it so
c4 so a little by little making progress
and here we have Queen to f2 check my
Carlson with rook to e3 and now comes
Queen to d2 again with check and with
this movie
we reached move ad and it was in this
position that Maxie matter who resigned
the game which is just insane that
has so many so many positions were
possible so many ideas were winning
India in Indian we we reached this King
King rook and pawn versus King and Queen
which is just insane and here Marco
resigns because he's losing the C pawn
and then it's just the field or endgame
for example if you play Kingdom efore
you're getting just Queen d5 check with
this picks up the pawn and then it's
straight forward from there
and if you play rook to d3 it's similar
Queen to f4 check the King is now forced
to c3 with check discovering the check
but now you get King to c5 and again
there's no way there is no way to defend
the pawn here so once again we would
reach the Philidor endgame
so really just insane stuff after Queen
today to check Matlock who resigned the
game and a very important victory for
Crossan because it well I'm not gonna
discuss the standings just yet as we're
gonna show tomorrow I'm gonna try and
throw a bit a few more games as I didn't
show any any yesterday I was really busy
sorry about that but we're gonna discuss
the standings then before we go into the
final round but this is across the 100
game that he went undefeated so he
reached the dings ding Lorenza unbeaten
streak so he needs one more game
tomorrow's game not to lose the to get a
hundred and one games unbeaten which
sort of is a world record but Sergei TV
I Cove and the Bogota knowledge I
believe have 110 games although those
games are not on the highest level such
as these games so you know it's a
different kind of record but you know if
Carson doesn't lose for example at least
11 more games in class but I'm
controlled then he will break those
records as well and he says that you
know he broke pretty much all the
records in chess there are so this is
one record that he's very much looking
forward to so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it
I would like to thank giunta's boom
Bruce boom Bruce for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the isle of
man chess tournament is getting very
excited to see who will be the final
candidate for the candidates tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course checking up on
whatever else is happening in the chess
world so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day